[Music]
to the viewers at home everybody in the
audience knows this I like to come out
and talk to the audience a little bit
before the show and actually somebody
brought a wonderful gift that I think
fans of the show will also appreciate
Oren can I get that please this is made
by Christine here in the second row and
she made wash and damn towels laundry
detergent which is perfect thank you so
much that means a lot I love this we're
gonna try can we get that on the set can
we what do we have to pay her couldn't
we just screw well screw her over if you
know if we can screw over let's I mean
let's talk about it later but if we can
if we can find a way to use her art
without compensating her in any way
let's even cut this little
acknowledgment bit out and just have it
there and we'll tell them that I made it
cuz I'm a big boy thank you so much for
seeing that as lovely Thank You PJ I
recently went out of town with the San
Francisco on my favorite cities yeah the
best part of the trip though it wasn't
the Golden Gate Bridge it wasn't Haight
Ashbury it wasn't even seeing the full
house house although it was fun to see
where the Michelle's grew up you know I
always find and be like look that's
where I'm Becky got stuffed by Uncle
Jesse
stuffed the best part of the whole trip
was staying in a hotel I love hotels I
know that sounds crazy some people hate
them they go in all investigative
reporter like look at these sheets watch
these now watch these sheets is a
blacklight they're awesome
felting probably I'll wash the sheets
hey Larry David relax they wash the
sheets in fact they washed him today to
day and every day
when's the last time you washed your
sheets I haven't washed my sheets in
ever cuz I'm grown I could spill hot tar
on my bed you know what I'd do I'd find
a creative way to sleep on the other
side that's why you get a queen but in a
hotel that's clean they clean it you're
taken care of and that's why I love it a
hotel is like a giant mom you run out of
soap hotel mom's like don't worry Petey
needs soap get my boy some soap send up
some soap to my boy
but if I'm in my apartment I don't have
soap I just don't have soap
I'm just looking under the sink like can
I put Ajax on the ball that's a big no
by the way that is a big no a hotel room
is like the apartment I always dreamed
about we all dreamt about when we were
kids you got the big-screen TV two beds
I don't need two beds and jumping on one
jump into the other one there's even
that tiny tree house fridge and it's
stuffed with after cook after school
snacks you know I mean got cold jelly
beans the round pretzel is easy on the
molars level even the alcohols
child-sized you know they got those
little bottles I like to pretend they're
like regular size bottles but there's
like a baby bartender there's a little
PD want a widdle vodka cran boy yes I do
baby bartender and room serves that's
like a fifth graders dream come true
I feel like Richie Rich even then not
him that nice of a hotel you can pick up
the phone order anything you want
suddenly a fancy guy shows up in a
bowtie with one of those silver domes
like a little surprise party for your
food your chicken tenders Master Holmes
Thank You Noonan yeah
keep a finger for your trouble not every
hotel is the same though every Hotel is
a hotel mom but the difference between
like a nice hotel and a cheap motel is
who hotel mom married it's true saying
like a fancy hotel it's kind of like
your hotel mom married like a rich new
stepdad he's got all these weird new
rules like don't open the windows
they're decorative the TV has a built-in
volume restriction there's a bidet yeah
I summered in the South of France very
common over there now scrub your
undercarriage I mean so out of touch he
has no idea what a fair price is for a
bottle of water yeah eight ounces of
Dasani 1350 what he's had a lot too you
a cheap motel on the other hand it's
like the weekend dad that wants to win
you over by letting you do whatever you
want yeah sure you can smoke cigarettes
on the vibrating bed go out it in fact
the smoke keeps the rats out
now listen here young man one more
pay-per-view softcore lesbian porn and
it's off to bed JK JK I bought a whole
block of softcore lesbian porn
dad it's fun dance with your Tomo my
favorite part of salmon hotel is whether
it's nice or rundown you can still close
all the 13 layers of blackout curtains I
love that you don't get that at home
just like wrap yourself in all seven
blankets bury your head in all 26
pillows they think you need and you feel
like you're back in the womb you know if
twice a day a Guatemalan lady knocked on
my mother's vagina to see if I needed to
[Applause]
[Music]